[Music]
he'll candidly clarifies his
controversial Oprah Winfrey post after
the 54 year old singer shared this meme
of Oprah kissing Harvey Weinstein on
Wednesday that read when you have been
part of the problem for decades but
suddenly they all think here's a
solution he seemingly suggested in the
caption that Oprah knew the Hollywood
producer was mistreating women writing
you'd heard the rumors but you had no
idea he was actually Sarah Lee
assaulting young starry-eyed actresses
on Thursday seal clarified his comments
in a facebook video now let's get
straight to it let me start by saying
that I have an enormous amount of
respect for everything that Oprah has
achieved and contributed in her life
what I reposted was not an attack on
Oprah at all she just happened to be the
person photographed with the pig in the
picture no what I repost it was
commentary on the hypocritical and
double standard nature and behavior of
Hollywood then he slammed foxnews for
interpreting his post as anti Oprah
along with stacey dash who tweeted that
he made a good point
stacey dash keep my name out of your
mouth do not retweet re-quote anything I
have said in order to reinforce your
self-hating agenda you live in the
sunken place again this was not an
attack against Oprah this was an
observation of the toxic nature of
Hollywood and I believe that a conscious
people our progressive people